a new book appears to reveal the
behind-the-scenes
turmoil that led to prince harry and
megan split from the royal family
finding freedom was co-authored by two
royal reporters who were granted
unique access to those closest to harry
and megan
according to the publisher mark phillips
is outside buckingham palace in london
good morning mark
good morning well the coronavirus may
still be raging and the economy may
still be tanking
but harry and megan's disenchantment
with the royal family is once again
the talk of the town they say they
didn't write the book
and they said they didn't help the two
royal writers who did
but few in palace circles or who follow
the family
closely think harry and megan didn't
have something to do with it
the official line from the sussex's is
that um harry and megan
didn't collaborate with this book but my
understanding
is that they did actually collaborate
very closely with the authors
and helped authorize access to their
friends
among the juicier points the book claims
that william took what harry felt was a
snobbish attitude toward megan
when the couple first started seeing
each other take as much time as you need
to get to know this girl
william is alleged to have said harry
bristled at the phrase
this girl and reportedly chose to
interpret it not as friendly brotherly
advice
but his reluctance to accept megan the
fact that william also reportedly said
harry had been blinded by lust
allegedly didn't help megan an american
actress with a mixed racial background
was accompanied down the aisle at the
wedding by prince charles
because her estranged father wasn't
there but that gesture was not a sign of
acceptance
according to the book their friends are
also quoted as saying
harry and megan were kept at a distance
by william and kate
and that no support was offered to megan
the outsider
when she needed it megan's friends claim
she told them she had given up her whole
life
to become one of the royals but received
not thanks
but death by a thousand cuts from the
family
and palace staff there's something about
her i don't trust
one senior official is reported to have
said the notion that
people weren't welcoming to her right
from the start
the royal family will be quite stunned
by that when harry and megan finally
severed their royal
ties they had hopes of continuing a
part-time relationship with the family
here
that prospect appears to be even more
unlikely now
there was a lot of hurt after they left
the uk
and i think that hurt is only going to
be exacerbated and deepened on
publication of this book
despite their protest that they didn't
write the book it's being widely
perceived here as sympathetic
to harry and megan the palace of course
hasn't commented
there's an old expression here jerica
you can't be a part-time
royal that's especially true now all
right our full-time reporter mark
phillips in london for us thank you